every pattern that exists in a
relationship is co-created you have a
role and they have a role it's not 100
on them it's not 100 on you it's always
shared responsibility so you can never
control what somebody else does like
you'll never be able to control how
somebody shows up or how they respond
but you can always take accountability
and take control for how you decide to
respond to something in every situation
where you're feeling activated or
triggered or you notice that there's a
pattern that's existing and you find
yourself pointing the finger at the
other person a much more effective
technique would be like okay point it in
how am i contributing to this pattern
this cycle that exists between me and my
partner because it's not you versus them
that's a huge misconception it's not me
versus you it's me and you versus the
pattern we're on the same team here how
can we both do what we need to in order
to dissolve this pattern and oftentimes
that comes down to
saying the hard things the depth of your
intimacy
is directly proportional to how many
uncomfortable conversations you're
willing to have with your partner in
that moment when he said okay i have to
tell you this thing and i knew what was
coming and it just really felt like my
world was crumbling apart i also knew
that
if i were to
explode with a huge reaction how could
you do this to me flip the table over
start you know throwing things at him if
i did that all i would be doing is
validating his fear that it's not always
safe to tell the truth whether or not we
stay together i wanted him to know that
being a person of integrity is far more
important than
piling lies on top of lies on top of
lies to get what you want from people
that was nema and bianca a couple well
known in the nutrition and fitness world
who in the last year came out with a
podcast episode on their own show called
we are not your couple's goals choosing
to share some vulnerable relationship
experiences that they've had which led
them to working through childhood
traumas healing from infidelity and
showing up for both themselves and their
partner nema's bodybuilding career took
off after switching from being
vegetarian his whole life and never have
eaten meat to a 100 plant-based vegan
diet in 2015 motivated by a desire to
live as healthy a lifestyle as he can
lima is living testimony that you can
build incredible strength and muscle
without animal foods and be healthy and
bianca is a vegan fitness influencer who
also has a coaching and mentorship
business and inspires others in
liberation and empowerment all around
the world so together they started
touching on other topics and opening up
more about their relationship on their
own podcast and i immediately knew i
wanted to get them on my show i love the
premise they speak of relationships are
an opportunity to grow deeper within
ourselves we cover their relationship
story how personal growth is imperative
for long-term relationship success
what a conscious relationship is
breaking generational trauma and how the
way we parent creates a ripple effect
for our children as they face the world
their advice for healing both personally
and within their relationships how to
have healthy communication and resolve
conflict in a positive productive way
creating safe containers for each other
during triggering and vulnerable times
openness to grow and heal and so much
more i thoroughly enjoyed this
conversation and i find this topic so
meaningful and enriching to our lives i
hope you enjoy it let's get into it
thanks so much for coming on this
podcast i'm so excited for this
conversation and i think to start off
i'd love to for you guys to share a
little bit about why the topic of
relationships and healing your traumas
to grow together is such an important
one for you that you're so passionate
about like maybe can you can share a
little bit about your story how you guys
started out together and what unfolded
yeah well thanks for having us here we
love talking about this stuff and we're
both passionate about talking about
relationships because we've learned
so much in the container of our
relationship over the past it's been a
little bit over five years now i mean
more than i've learned in all of these
other courses that i've done and i've
been in therapy for years and i've
learned so much individually but
together we've been able to just
transcend so much pain and trauma and
patterns and you know behavioral things
that we had that we didn't like about
ourselves that we were able to grow out
of and so that's why we've seen how much
it's impacted us so we've just become
really passionate about sharing it with
other people
yeah definitely i mean all relationships
are a container for growth and a
container for reflection and sometimes
it's difficult to
grow or learn about yourselves in a
vacuum like with no other person there
to reflect these parts of yourself that
may be dormant that become triggered
when the right set of circumstances
present themselves so romantic
relationships especially if you think
about
friendships like you might get triggered
in some ways with friends and people you
know or co-workers or bosses but
romantic relationships are really
rooted in our most fundamental like
childhood wounds that are related to our
parents or our primary caretakers and
when those get activated it's a whole
new set of skills that's required to
navigate those and if you're not taught
those things which not many of us are
we're just learning on the fly
it can be a real challenge to
find yourself in the same situation over
and over and never be able to transcend
that so
luckily we
have a relationship where we're both
really committed to working through
those really challenging conversations
and transcending them and not allowing
them to continue to repeat on this cycle
and that's what allowed us to
i mean have so much personal growth not
just you know
like from a from a romantic level but in
all other areas of life we've been able
to take these lessons and put it into
business put it into the type of content
that we share put it into
our our employees and our co-workers so
everything that we do so that's why
we're really passionate about it yeah
and i guess to share a little bit about
our story which you know we have shared
online so i know you know a little bit
about it um
we met in 2017 and we had a long
distance relationship at first i was in
florida and i was in california and so
with that
start to our relationship we really just
created a best friend bond right away
because there wasn't any physical
intimacy right away it was just long
conversations long face time calls
sending each other pictures all the time
and we really became best friends and so
the first year of our relationship you
know i i moved after six months across
the country actually to long beach
yeah that was where we spent the first
two years together of our relationship
and in those first two years i mean we
knew
we we thought we knew what we were
bringing to the relationship right
everyone knows you bring your baggage
into the relationship but we really had
so much more that
stuff i didn't know i was bringing into
the relationship and same for him and
we began triggering each other's our
insecurities started coming out and we
were
um
adapting the only way we knew how which
was just how how we saw our parents
act how we've shown up in in past
relationships and that's just how we
showed up because we didn't know any
better and it wasn't until a couple
years in
that we had some massive break
breakthroughs and that started with us
taking the initiative to grow together
and
i i was in therapy for a while and then
i started having different coaches and
mentors and then we got a coach
a coaching container together and in
that coaching container i mean we really
were forced to look at the patterns that
we had which was i was a major people
pleaser and
this is something a lot of people do and
we don't realize it but people pleasing
is another form of manipulation you want
somebody to like you or love you and so
you do what you think they want you to
do even though it's not what you want so
everybody's losing because you're not
being honest with them and you're not
being honest with yourself so you're
making yourself miserable so whether
that was you know nema wanted to go to
the gym and i really wanted to stay home
i would force myself to go to the gym
because i thought he wanted to go with
me and really he just needed some space
like that's just a little small example
yeah pleasing right but of just the
power of communication exactly and and
honesty you know truthfulness and so i
was a major people pleaser and then
nemai had his own
not so great patterns around dishonesty
and he and and suppression and and
hiding things and that came from his own
childhood trauma
yeah i mean going back to originally
what you said in the beginning about how
our
art what we need to work on and our
deepest traumas are best reflected like
when we have someone with us is so true
because you can't really i mean you can
work on yourself by yourself but it's
also there's another layer and a
different way to learn about yourself
with someone else and it reminds me of
like my kids you know because i think
it's similar different obviously but
similar in the fact that like our kids
are really our reflections of us they're
little mirrors that show us they reflect
back to us what we're doing and a lot of
times we look at children and we're like
how could they do that and then if you
really take a step back you realize they
learned it from you that you're the one
who's doing that and that's why they're
acting like that and so same situation
with relationships like if you're able
to open up and be willing to learn about
yourself and learn how to grow through
seeing what's happening and playing out
in your relationship like that's how
you're able to like grow together bond
together and have a deeper relationship
because i think a lot of times
relationships get in this stuck place
where you kind of get in this like
we just fell apart or we're just not in
love anymore you know i just we just
grew apart when really how often if we
just allow ourselves to be willing to
grow if we have those vulnerable
communication like conversations and
everything that your go that you guys
have gone through to be able to grow
better together and like grow deeper in
love
yeah exactly yeah and there's there's
i mean this may not be true for
everybody but i see it i've seen it in
our relationship and i've seen it in
other friends relationships as well is
that there comes a point where there's
like
complacency that happens in the
relationship where you both just accept
that things are
the way they are
and
we are both so dedicated towards our own
personal growth that that doesn't allow
like space for that to happen in our
relationship because if she's growing
she's learning about herself and showing
up in a new way which then forces me to
have to
like
like follow suit or or learn about
myself and how this is changing me as
well so it's like this constant dance
that we're doing where we're both
growing and then bringing what we take
what we learn into the relationship to
deepen the intimacy because we're
constantly getting to know each other
who we were whenever we first met
are completely different versions of
ourselves and who we are now five years
later and if you're both not on this
same growth trajectory then that gap
kind of widens if one person is growing
and the other person is just kind of
staying complacent and stagnant then
there's a lot more room for for friction
for
confrontation for
unhappiness for all of these different
things so
yeah i think growth is a big part of our
relationship as well yeah there's a
really common misconception that you
need to
work on yourself and figure it all out
and then you can meet the love of your
life and live happily ever after and
everybody's stories are different of
course there are a lot of cases i have
friends who have met each other after
they've both done a lot of work it
doesn't mean that they're not going to
do work together but you know me and em
i met when we were
pretty young and so
the opportunity for us to learn more
about ourselves and each other and how
to love and how to relate to each other
and how to communicate i mean our
relationship has been the classroom for
that so i i don't really believe that
you need to work on yourself you need to
fix yourself before you're ready for
love because when you find somebody
who's also you know has a growth mindset
and is really passionate about
doing the work and like healing from
that deep childhood trauma the stuff
that you don't want to talk about all
that shadowy stuff when you meet
somebody else who wants to do that with
you i mean they just continue to pull
they pull you up and you pull them up
like what nemai was saying you grow a
little bit you pull them up then they
grow a little bit and they pull you up
and then you keep going until you
experience a whole new type of living
yeah that growth mindset is so pivotal
and it's really hard if one of the
persons in the relationship is all about
the growth mindset and the other person
is just like yeah i'm fine where i'm at
like why do we got to do this kind of
work you know it can be really hard for
that couple to be on the same wavelength
because like you said one's kind of
growing in this direction the other it
almost feels like you're kind of getting
pulled in the opposite direction when
your partner is kind of not growing with
you and andrew and i had a really young
relationship as well we got together we
were 15 and 16. so we're completely
different people than we were when we
were 15 and 16. and that's why i think
most young really young relationships
don't last because you change and you
grow and then you learn okay this
person's not the right person for me but
for some reason it could have just been
our compatibility but also it was that
we were constantly growing together and
all the best parts of him i was able to
take from and learn
from him in those ways and then the best
parts of me that i was strong in
he was able to grow and learn from and
as a result we like helped each other to
just be the best the better versions of
ourselves as we were getting older you
know yeah yeah but so how has your
relationship evolved through um the
traumas that you experienced when you
were young when you started to realize
that you needed to work through these
things like how did you guys decide or
come to that point where you realized
that you need to address those things in
your relationship yeah well
i mean so so with our
particular situation when i met nemai he
had
a lot of childhood trauma that he hadn't
really faced yet
other than just like really gently
acknowledging like that's there but it
was in the past and it's in the past
it's in the past and i can move forward
right and where i had been actively
dealing with my trauma a little bit more
through
therapy and coaching and um i still had
ways to go and i'm we're both still
working on stuff now i think it's kind
of a never-ending journey right it is
yeah yeah and um so we got to a point in
our relationship um this was about in
2020 so we were a couple of three and a
half years into our relationship where
um our relationship was kind of at a
standstill where we were like okay we
need to either grow or we're
we're not going to be able to stay
together and in that
time that was when nemai was like okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna face some of this
stuff and that came with being
vulnerable about talking about stuff
that he had never talked about before
i'm talking about it with other you know
coaches and mentors and a therapist and
um
even just by doing that by being more
vulnerable i was able to understand him
better because i'm like oh like now i
can see the
little boy that felt unsafe or
unacknowledged or or needed something
that he didn't receive and i know how to
not necessarily give that to him because
it's not my responsibility to be his
parent but to support him while he
re-parents himself and we did break up
and we took time apart which was really
necessary for our journey but that was
kind of where that started and then
now you know still always working
through that now in 2022 i'm revisiting
some of my childhood stuff that i didn't
face and same neem is holding space for
me while i'm
re-parenting that inner child that
didn't receive you know the love or the
care of the safety that she needed and
so that's kind of how i like to look at
it it's not so much of saying okay my my
my partner had this
horrible childhood trauma and so they
need me to love them and they need me to
take care of them and to be their mommy
or be their dad rescue them to rescue
them that's not necessarily
good for the relationship because then
it can just create codependency and it's
not actually helping the person
transcend that pain but it's more so
creating the space
where they can re-parent themselves and
saying i love you i accept you no matter
how much you have to cry over this how
much you need to be held do you need me
to sit here and be your shoulder do you
need me to watch a movie with you do you
need me to go to therapy with you
whatever you know whatever it is for
them to um to to strengthen themselves
that's really how you can how you can
support that that journey
yeah and so can you explain a little bit
further into
maybe the other parts of your
relationship about like the infidelity
and how that happened how you guys grew
from that because a lot of people that's
like something that people don't really
talk about oh yeah people don't and i
actually made a post on instagram
talking about because we've done a
couple episodes on both of our podcasts
i did um i made a post on instagram
talking about people don't like to talk
about healing from infidelity people
talk about infidelity in the sense of um
you know it's unacceptable when you have
a monogamous relationship and and that
happens and you know moving on but
people don't talk about um the healing
in the sense of because whether you
decide to start a new relationship with
that person or stay together or break up
and never speak to them again that pain
of infidelity and and
your trust being broken you will take
that with you if you don't heal it so
i'm i like talking about healing it and
um i mean we can share a little bit
about for people that are you know
watching or listening and don't don't
know us don't know your story yeah don't
know our story so um so like i said um
after we had been together for three and
a half years we got to a point where we
were like okay we need to basically grow
or die like there was a lot of stuff
coming to the surface childhood stuff
old stuff and we were in a container
with two relationship coaches and they
you know said bianca your people pleaser
and nima you're not being honest and
somewhere in that container nemai
wanted to come forward with his truth
which was that early on in our
relationship he had been unfaithful and
it was
a lot for me to handle because part of
my trauma as a child was that my dad was
unfaithful of course so it was kind of
the perfect little puzzle piece to just
reactivate that and be like wow like
everybody cheats on me nobody chooses me
first like that was the one of my one of
my wounds and um the way that i chose to
handle that situation was to end our
relationship which was really hard i
mean we had businesses together we lived
together all of our friends were just
like one big friend group so you know i
really just like ripped the
the tablecloth out from under my life
but i was like i need to
end this relationship not because i
don't love this person or because i
think it's impossible to forgive him but
because
this is not
what is okay like these are my
boundaries you know i i don't want to be
in a relationship where cheating is okay
so i ended the relationship and we took
time apart we were actually
officially broken up for nine months but
in those nine months we did see each
other on and off for some period
sometimes we would go period without
speaking and that was when you know that
really was like the thing that ignited
nemai to be like i want to be the man
that
i know i can be which i'll let him speak
on
but um and that was really where he
started um
like really just went into so much
growth so i'll let you share a little
bit about that yeah yeah so back
we'll backpedal a little bit because
there's a lot obviously we're trying to
condense this for this conversation but
uh condensed like a year's worth of
events but um
yeah for me whenever i
entered this coaching container with
these relationship coaches
one of the first things that we talked
about was not our relationship it was my
childhood and my past and my history and
things that i hadn't talked about for i
was 29 years old i'd never even
vocalized them out loud like never spoke
the words out loud and i won't go into
too much detail about it but essentially
the story that i had told myself was
that it was unsafe to tell the truth
so if that story was so deeply ingrained
in my fabric of who i was
it would present itself in many
different areas and the safe thing for
me to do was to
tell a half-truth you know embellish or
um
withhold information so
that's kind of how this pattern had that
had existed through adolescence into
early adulthood into us meeting
i was already so deeply
kind of like
in this pattern that you can't see it
and it's like one of the hardest or like
most dangerous lies that you can tell
are the lies to yourself and if you
believe those lies then you're oblivious
to the way that you show up
and i'm not trying to absolve myself of
responsibility or accountability for the
way i showed up then but that was just
kind of where it stemmed from and i
didn't have the awareness of it so in
this container we talked about that and
so we really worked through a lot of my
childhood stuff and saw the the
the relationship between like my
childhood and how it was showing up in
in my romantic relationship and one of
the exercises that they shared with me
that were like we want you to go through
and
be as honest
as you can be with anything that you've
ever
like
embellished lied flat out or told half
truth so i went deep into my memory bank
and started like listing off all the
things that i was not in integrity or
where the areas where i wasn't in
integrity and i brought that to
to bianca and it was like
the hardest thing you have to do because
it's not only you have to bring it and
you know that what you share is going to
really hurt the person that you love but
you also have to confront yourself and
be like wow i've i've been
not a great person and i have to like
accept that and and really own it before
i can move forward and then it must have
even been scary just to do that because
of the traumas that you experienced
growing up where it's not safe to tell
the truth so that must have been really
hard so that was the thing that was like
the
that was the key to unlock
like the person that i really wanted to
be because i knew that there were some
things that i could have kept to myself
and took with me to the grave and i had
a really honest conversation with myself
and i said if i do this
then
i will always have shame and i will
always
not be able to fully love myself for who
i am and i need to
speak this truth even if it means my
entire life comes crumbling down because
i need to allow this part of myself to
be seen so that i can
step forward into becoming the man that
i want to be so i had talked to her and
scheduled this
this you know meeting with her and
um shared with her these this infidelity
that
was the hardest thing for me to do and
she
sat there and
took it
when i say took it i mean she
thanked me for sharing my truth even
though i it really pained her and it was
like obviously very hurtful for her and
her
saying that in that way was exactly like
the thing that the little boy in me
needed to feel loved and unconditionally
accepted for making mistakes for uh for
hurting her even
though it wasn't what she wanted to hear
yeah and and also you know me knowing
because leading up to this his like
truth telling
i was you know he was going through this
his childhood trauma things he had never
spoken about before and
that unders i knew that one of his
deepest wounds was feeling like it was
not safe to tell the truth
and
also if you add on to you know why
why is somebody unfaithful there's so
many different reasons and this reason
another one of his wounds was you know a
feeling of unworthiness and like that
can show up in kind of seeking attention
and
attention and love or lust from other
people and so i had an awareness of this
it didn't make receiving that
information easier and like i said that
information was the perfect puzzle piece
for my trauma which was
you know i'm i'm never somebody's first
choice or i'm always lied to like i'm
always taken for granted like that was
my wound but
i in in that moment when he said okay i
have to tell you this thing and i knew
what was coming and it just really felt
like my world was
crumbling apart i also knew that
if i were to
explode
with a huge reaction how could you do
this to me flip the table over start you
know throwing things at him if i did
that all i would be doing is validating
his fear that it's not always safe to
tell the truth and unfortunately there
are a lot of cases when you do tell the
truth and people meet you with reactions
of course when we say it's safe to tell
the truth i can't speak on behalf of
every single person in the world right
but in our
particular situation
i knew that i could create safety for
him to tell the truth because
whether or not we stay together
or we we get back together or whatever
that what was going to happen beyond
that point i wanted him to know that
being a person of integrity is far more
important than
piling lies on top of lies on top of
lies to get what you want from people
and me dealing with the pain of feeling
like people lie to me or people don't
people break my trust that's a separate
like that's a separate thing for me to
deal with that was not for me to deal
with right here and i think that
something that i always um something
i've learned with relationships is when
we deal with all these different
problems a lot of times they all kind of
compile and becomes this like big
abstract mess of your trauma and my
trauma and then the thing that's
happening now and how that's creating
trauma in the present moment and it
becomes so overwhelming but if you can
try to just deal with things one chunk
at a time so in this moment the thing we
needed to deal with was his trauma with
feeling safe to tell the truth and me
creating that safety so when he told me
that you know i was unfaithful to you
early in our relationship it broke my
heart and i said thank you for telling
me and you know i was of course i was
like really upset and i was really
disappointed but you know thank you for
telling me the way we kind of look at um
you know not to like comparing my to a
child but if
if a child and i'm sure you know this if
they do something on that's not
great like they they break something or
they lie or they cheat on a test but
then they come to you and they tell you
okay mom i did this thing and i'm really
upset that i did it and if you say how
could you do that and you like you know
give them some sort of like uh
extreme reaction extreme reaction then
that that just further validates okay
i'm
i can't tell this person things that are
truthful so in that moment you know that
was his his inner child saying like okay
it's safe to tell the truth i have to
tell you this thing and meanwhile adult
nehemiah really disappointed me really
did break my heart but i had to let him
know it's safe to tell the truth thank
you for telling me and then we can move
on to the next thing which is okay the
relationship in the present can't we
can't stay together anymore because i'm
glad that you told me that thank you and
it also wasn't okay
we had a monogamous agreement when we
entered our relationship together and so
i have to end the relationship and that
was really hard too because i didn't
want to like we had our whole life built
together but i had to i had to do that
for myself and for
for him to you know understand that i
take my boundaries very seriously and i
think that this is where people who
experience infidelity trauma can really
it's really hard when you you love
someone and you want to be with them and
you know you live together maybe you
have kids together there's so many
different like components that can make
it easy to just say like okay like let's
you know like not break up or like what
you know whatever but um for me breaking
up was a really important boundary that
i had to set so i did that and then we
were able to move on into like the next
kind of like the next thing which was
then me dealing with that pain of like
my own self-worth okay well i felt like
i had low self-worth when i was a kid
and i found out that my dad cheated on
my mom and felt like he cheated on me
right and then now the person that i
love cheated on me so what does that
mean does it mean that everybody cheats
on me and that i'm unworthy of love no i
know that that's not what that means so
i had to do my own self-work and that
really didn't involve
nemai actually it was really me my
therapist my support team i had a coach
for a period of time i read lots of
books i journaled i meditated i mean i
was showing up for myself every day
sitting there sometimes crying for an
hour if i had to and then when i when
when it was appropriate for him to
support me i said hey i need you to
support me in this and what i'm going
through and that was kind of how we
started to to go through that and then
eventually we found our way back to each
other um which wasn't planned we fully
let go of the relationship but we on our
way back
wow that is such an like a powerful
story because i keep thinking back to
like child nema and i'm thinking to all
the parents listening right now how
important this message is to remind
parents how to respond to your children
when they tell the truth because there
are so many adults walking around that
have a very similar wound in their heart
and have a really hard time telling the
truth i mean i know a lot of people with
that kind of wound where they felt that
when they were younger if they told the
truth
and it was scary to do so and they had
their vulnerability and said i'm going
to tell my parents because they
originally trusted their parents like
the the number one people that they
trust and then that pair the parents
either had an extreme reaction
punishment discipline shame all those
things and it all adds up over time
to where they become afraid to tell the
truth and feel like it's not safe and
you have to
start doing white lies or doing half
shoes like you said and it goes into
adulthood which affects all the
relationships in your life not just your
um like romantic relationship but
friendship relationships then it plays
out in relationships with your own kids
and a lot of times our parents have
their own set of wounds that they
haven't done work to heal from their
childhood it's like this endless cycle
and that's why i think this conversation
of truly doing inner work to heal your
wounds
whatever it takes whether like you're
saying reading books doing therapy and
then having that ability and just
openness to
open your heart to that communication
and vulnerability to actually do the
work really goes such a long way like
it's like a ripple effect to the next
generation yeah yeah it is it is how we
it's how we break generational trauma
essentially yeah and i was gonna say
that that
that's a it's a if you look at it that
way
you know pain that may have started
generations before you your great great
great great grandparents or whoever so
many generations before you there's
momentum that comes along with each
generation so i like to look at it or
just like use this analogy of like a
train you know like each generation is a
cart on a train and the more carts it
has the more momentum it the more force
it's required to stop to stop it from
moving or slow it down so whenever you
are
chosen by
divine or your ancestors or you know
make the the conscious decision to be
the one that stops that
generational
trauma
it is a lot like it is a a big burden to
bear so it's not easy
but on the other side of that
you do break the chain and you break
that cycle for now that i know how to
move through this
this these situations
whenever i have children i'll be able to
really instill this like integrity and
honesty as a part of who they are from
the very beginning because it's it's not
always like i'm not even blaming my
parents i don't i really want to make
this clear i don't blame my parents for
me having this story my story is my
story and i somehow form this story as
in as a protective adaptation for
something that happened to me whenever i
was a kid it's not necessarily their
fault at all and
i had a lot of shame that i put on top
of myself that was preventing me from
being authentic because shame lives in
silence and if you never share it with
anybody nobody really knows the pain
that you're holding on to so part of my
thing was also to no longer be available
for that shame so i had to let my
parents know too i i had this really
tough conversation with them that
i recognize now that a lot of the shame
that i had was was handed to me through
them it wasn't ever mine to begin with
and i let them know i was no longer
available for that and that i'm going to
speak my truth whenever i want to and it
was hard for them to hear but it heals
both ways in both directions so not as
not only is it healing for me and my
future generations but it heals
backwards for my parents as well because
they learned a lot from that
conversation too and were able to
accept um themselves a lot more and find
peace with things that happened in the
past as well so it was it was it was a
really powerful um event for for us to
happen that all stemmed from our
relationship and
moving forward to whenever we got back
together and decided to
share this stuff publicly like
that was a huge step forward for me
because vulnerability was not my strong
suit it was it was a muscle that i had
not exercised at all so whenever we got
back together we wanted to to share what
we had learned
and i i went into it fully knowing that
i was going to be judged online people
are going to have their opinions and
anytime you open up your
personal relationship to the internet
people are going to have unsolicited
opinions and and all day they'll have
they'll find something to talk about and
something to you know crucify you for
and
i knew that by me sharing my truth it
would give other people especially men
permission to be authentic to be
vulnerable to
see that it's okay to make a mistake if
you you own it and you decide to be
better moving forward so that was my
thing was like how can i live in
integrity moving forward and i'm not
ashamed of what i did i'm
it was a painful lesson for for everyone
involved but looking back at it now that
painful lesson was um
you know the catalyst it was a it was a
catalyst for so much so much growth in
my life and so much
freedom in my life and hopefully freedom
for other people too because
we we we live in this this cancel
culture society where people somebody
makes a mistake and done they're done
doesn't matter what they did before
doesn't matter what they're gonna do in
the future they're done they're forever
branded as that whatever they got
canceled for so i think that people
change you know we we have to create a
space for opportunity to realize that
you know we're so multifaceted and
there's so much more than just what you
see on the surface so to take something
for face value and judge it immediately
like maybe just pause and reflect and
ask yourself some questions before you
leave that hateful comment before you
jump to some kind of conclusion like
we're all humans here we're all
imperfect like nobody that you know
everyone's just doing their best exactly
exactly yeah and you know when we did
open up with this story after we got
back together you know when we decided
to get back together we
started a new relationship we didn't
pick up where we left off we started a
completely new relationship with new
new boundaries new rules new intentions
we were we spent the whole first year
back together going to therapy
a combined total of three times a week
once once a week once a week for myself
once a week for him and then once a week
together and we had coaches and we and
we had coaches and we had coaches as
well i had my own coach he had his own
coach we were doing individual very
intentional work as well as very
intentional work together as a couple we
were reading you know a lot of books and
a lot of material to constantly
integrate into our relationship and when
we decided okay we want to share this
story because we feel like it can help
people and it can give people permission
to start living in
integrity and also permission for people
on the other side of the this type of
situation of an infidelity situation to
be strong in their boundaries and also
to not
take somebody and just
take one thing that they've done and sum
that up to who they are right and of
course every situation is unique are
there people who
um you know cheat and abusive patterns
and know what know that what they're
doing is hurtful and continue to do it
regardless sure that's definitely a
situation in which case would be
considered really unhealthy and again
it's like setting that
setting that boundary and saying this is
not okay and i'm leaving this
relationship there's so many different
variables but in our situation it was
something that um
we we chose to
handle it the way that we did and when
people online you know kind of just see
the headline of the podcast and they
don't sit and watch the whole thing and
they they immediately jump to you know
one's a cheater always a cheater i would
never take somebody back you know that's
just in those comments i just i just see
their pain because they they feel that
they wouldn't be able to forgive
themselves if they made a mistake that
big or they've been hurt that deeply and
they do not have it in them to hold
space for that that depth of forgiveness
but when it comes to healing from
infidelity whether you
stay with that person or get back
together with them
or never talk to them again forgiving
them is your key to freedom freedom if
you do not forgive somebody for
something that they did to hurt you and
you hold on to that you're using so much
energy inside your body to hold on to
this grudge of i will never forgive
somebody for doing that to me and you
will take that into your next
relationship and your next relationship
and you'll have a new partner who's
never done anything un unfaithful to you
and you'll be like what are you looking
at on your phone why are you following
this person why did you know why why are
you doing this why are you doing this
because you start projecting all that
pain that you didn't heal so i'm really
big on forgiveness and i'm really big on
compassion obviously you know i'm a
vegan compassion is my thing and i don't
only apply compassion to animals and
and and critters i apply compassion to
human beings as well meaning that if
somebody hurts me and makes a mistake i
let them know that's not okay but thank
you for telling me and this is how i'm
going to move forward from the situation
which might mean our relationship ends
our friendship ends i need space from
you maybe i never want to talk to you
again but i forgive you and that's how i
chose to heal from it and i honestly
like i can sit here and i can truthfully
say that i have healed from this
situation which was really hard because
like i said directly related to my
childhood trauma and you know anybody
who's been cheated on knows how how hard
it is but i truly like we've been able
to rebuild trust i trust other people in
my life i don't live in this constant
fear anymore that people are lying to me
like i really was able to
but to grow out of that and forgiveness
was really the key to it
wow everything you guys just said it was
so beautiful like from the forgiveness
factor to the the vulnerability
piece that you guys were willing to come
out and share because for anybody who
doesn't know them or their channel you
came out of the video called we are not
your couple's goals
and people are like what i'm i'm
imagining people looked up to you or
look up to you a lot in your
relationship and so that must have been
extremely vulnerable to share
that your whole story but i think it's
really beautiful that you saw the
goodness that comes out of that not only
from your own relationship and healing
your own traumas but also from being
willing to share your story because of
how many men like you said or women that
could see
how you guys grew from that situation
instead of living in their shame and
their fear because you were willing to
grow and willing to put yourself out
there and take a risk and also just
hold your child's self and just grow
from it and how many people are afraid
to do that so just seeing that as an
example i'm sure has impacted a lot of
people in their relationships
yeah yeah i would say that that
that one episode
we received more messages like i'm
talking about like lengthy dms and
messages than any other piece of content
that we've ever put out there yeah and
still it's it's constantly i mean
everywhere we go we meet people that say
oh i listened to that podcast and it
really helped me because you know i was
i was unfaithful or i was cheated on and
now i like was able to have more
understanding because it's a topic that
you know like you mentioned people don't
like to talk about it because it's
it's not a pretty subject to talk about
but it's really important and people do
make mistakes and people can change and
so i'm glad that we you know have been
able to talk about it and now we're at a
point in our relationship where we have
so much trust and love and it really is
a new relationship when we talk about
the past we refer to it as old
relationship we don't we don't say
oh yeah remember that time we say
remember that time in the old
relationship like we're really we really
kind of segment it like it is a part of
our our love story but it's also
not that we're not the same people that
we were right now absolutely yeah and
like a takeaway from this is that like
vulnerability and honesty is the key to
so many of our issues so many of our
inner problems and how hard it could be
it was for you and just seeing how you
healed that trauma and i love that you
said that you don't blame your parents
for it you look at at your experience
with your parents with empathy from
their own experiences as well but this
is i keep going going back to children
because it's generational like you said
it helps the past by being open and
honest talking to your parents but also
with future generations and i think i
know you guys don't have kids but the
book the conscious parent is really
amazing by shefali siberia i had her on
my podcast and um
it all comes back down to you and you
know how a lot of parents will be like
okay i need a book to like how to fix my
child why is my kids throwing tantrums
how do i fix it how do i stop my kid
from doing this or that and i'm like all
i love the respectful parenting books
because it always just turns it back on
you what are you doing
what are you doing
instead of being like my child my this
my that what they need to do it turns it
back on you and how you can grow because
when you're willing to grow and change
yourself it has a ripple effect on
everybody and every relationship around
you yeah yeah i like you're so right
because every every
every pattern it takes two to tango
right every every pattern that exists in
a relationship is co-created that you
have a role and they have a role it's
not
100
on them it's not 100 on you it's always
shared responsibility so you can never
control what somebody else does like
you'll never be able to control how
somebody shows up or how they respond
but you can always take accountability
and take control for how you decide to
respond to something so
in every situation where you're feeling
activated or triggered or you notice
that there's a pattern that's existing
and you find yourself pointing the
finger at the other person a much more
effective technique would be like okay
point it in and and use your eye and
really like turn it inward and say like
how am i contributing to this pattern
this cycle that exists between me and my
partner because it's not you versus them
that's a huge misconception it's not me
versus you it's me and you versus the
pattern and how can we
both we're on the same team here how can
we both do what we need to in order to
dissolve this pattern and oftentimes
that comes down to
saying the hard things like the like to
to to really the degree of like the the
depth of your intimacy is directly
proportional to how many uncomfortable
conversations you're willing to have
with your partner and
in any relationship if you are
holding up a mask and you have a mask
and you're constantly engaging with your
partner and they have a mask then
technically there's four people in the
relationship so it's like it's only once
we've removed those masks that you
really get to understand and meet the
person that you're engaging with and
deepen that sense of intimacy and
oftentimes it's on the other side of
those those hard truthful conversations
so this is kind of getting into like
conscious relationships and i know you
guys talk about how you're in a
conscious relationship so for people who
are listening who are interested in this
and they're like yeah i could really use
a lot more vulnerability openness
honesty and growth in my relationship
what is a conscious conscious
relationship and how do you embark on
that journey yeah that's a great
question i would i would call a
conscious relationship a relationship
that is intentional by
all the parties involved meaning that
when you get into the relationship and
you decide okay we're doing this we're
with each other in whatever capacity
that means that it's intentional it's
not just okay i like you and you like me
and we're just gonna
you know see where this goes but rather
you know not saying that you can't go up
the flow but okay we're gonna go up the
floor we're gonna see where this goes
but also these are my intentions for
myself and these are my intentions for
the relationship right and moving about
that in the most conscious way you can
so for us when we got back together and
we started this new relationship which
is you know a conscious relationship we
went into it saying okay
what are our intentions for the
relationship for the long term for the
short term for ourselves individually i
want to grow i want to
continue breaking because even though i
feel like i've broken my people pleaser
patterns of course every now and then it
rears its head right so it's i'm gonna
keep working on myself so that i can be
as authentic as possible as confident as
possible as honest as possible and we
can show up with integrity and i want to
have the type of relationship where i
can show up in this way right you're
very conscious of the way that you're
acting you're conscious of the trauma or
the the emotional baggage that you bring
in and you
every day you know whenever there's like
let's say there's a little bit of
tension like your partner did something
to upset you instead of just
you know rolling your eyes and leaving
and going to the gym and just avoiding
them completely or maybe just not
talking about it and waiting until you
cool down and moving on you say
hey i notice that you're upset with me
whenever you're ready i would really
like to have a conversation about this
because it doesn't feel good for me to
know that you're upset so when you're
ready i'm here to talk and then maybe
the other person might say something
like
you know thanks for acknowledging my
feelings i'm not ready to talk right now
let's reconvene in an hour that's how a
conscious couple
goes about problems instead of just
ignoring them until they go away because
they don't go away it's like literally
like a cartoon animal sweeping something
under a rug and then there's like a big
lump in the rug and then you trip on it
that's
that's what people do and that's what
we've been taught to do because
unfortunately we're not taught how to
relate to each other so that's how i
define a conscious relationship and um i
don't know if you want to share
what your definition no yeah
yeah i would i would agree with
everything that she said and i would say
i would add to that just really
having a framework to navigate
conflict because
that was
again it's not really something that
we're taught it's something that we
learn by witnessing other people and
most often times our parents so how did
they handle conflict well
my dad raised his voice he yelled he
gaslit and you know my mom just shut
down and like that was the pattern that
i saw so naturally as a boy i adopted
some of those qualities and
now whenever we have a conflict it like
she said we don't avoid it we we face it
head on but we have tools to navigate
those conflicts you know whenever she
shares whatever she has to share
i
validate what her experience by saying
like okay so what i'm hearing like
mirroring mirroring it yeah so what i'm
hearing is that you're upset because x y
and z so i so she knows that i hear
what she's really trying to communicate
and if i say it incorrectly she'll
say like yes and this this and that
so that's like one part of like the the
conflict resolution and then you know i
share my experience and then she says
the same thing and what that does is
just it defuses it depersonalizes the
the entire situation because it can feel
so so much like a personal attack and
every conflict is different i'm just you
know that sometimes it can be a personal
attack but most of the time it's just a
misunderstanding yeah and
what we do is now we have a framework to
operate within that will allow us to
understand each other better and not
allow these conflicts to like last a day
or we'll go to sleep angry or it'll be
like a whole week where there's just
tension between us we're like i can't
stand this tension between us let's i
don't it's uncomfortable but let's just
talk about it right here and now yeah
and i would say you know as far as how
to
how to embark on a conscious
relationship
i would say one is to
constantly check in with yourself to
know what you're bringing into the
relationship so if you don't know if you
have no idea what your
trauma may be or what your experiences
from the past that have created patterns
that you're bringing with you maybe
seeing a talk therapist or hiring a life
coach somebody that you can start to
talk to just one on one so you can
identify okay i didn't realize that i
tell a lot of white lies well i don't
really like that about myself or i have
a pattern of
being really secretive about things that
i'm shameful of or i have a pattern of
getting really uncomfortable around the
topic of sex and so i just avoid it
completely whatever
those things are you need to first
identify those things in yourself so
doing the work on your own
therapy journaling working with a coach
reading books and getting really really
honest with yourself so that's a
requirement by both of the parties and
then the other thing conflict resolution
just like what nema said and what he you
know gave an example of is essentially
essentially mirroring and naming the
feeling so if you can first learn how to
name your feelings this will just
transform all of your relationships this
is the biggest thing and this is
something that you know i know in in
conscious parenting it's like learning
how to
how teaching your kids how to identify
their feelings like i feel frustrated or
i feel
shameful or i feel happy like learning
how to identify those feelings we're not
taught how to do that as children or at
least our generation wasn't
unfortunately and so
doing that will just change your life
all of your relationships not just your
romantic one so whenever you feel
okay my partner
didn't
do something that he promised he was
supposed to plan a date night and he
didn't do it and i feel really upset
instead of
waiting until he says hey what's wrong
saying well i don't know i just feel
like you don't care about me and you
don't ever take initiative and it's all
i really want
your partner might be like whoa okay
you're upset about so much i literally
made one mistake yeah right so
naming your feelings would look like
saying okay it's also checking in with
yourself first again okay i i feel upset
i feel sad i feel forgotten like that's
really that's if you can condense it to
one word or just a couple words
i feel forgotten because you were
supposed to do this thing you promised
you would do this thing and you didn't
and if you can also identify how you can
relate that back to your childhood i
feel forgotten which reminds me of how
my parents used to never celebrate my
birthday and so i feel like i've been
forgotten my whole life now your partner
has context to understand why making
that one small mistake is so impactful
for you and that will just change that
will just completely change your
relationship and then the mirroring
piece is just when your partner says
that i feel forgotten you just say it
back to them and all that does is it
lets them know that you're listening so
then they feel like they're not being
ignored if you're looking at your phone
or if you're just nodding your head kind
of staring out into space they're like
are you you're not even listening i yeah
i don't i don't now they don't feel hurt
so just just saying i hear you you feel
forgotten and it relates back to how
your parents used to make you feel
forgotten i'm sorry that wasn't my
intention
let's let's move forward what can i do
to like help you like not feel forgotten
and feel seen and it's so much easier to
heal from an experience like that when
the other person is holding space for
you like that and you know because it's
easy when you're upset to be like you're
this and start name-calling or attacking
instead of identifying the feeling that
you're feeling and it's so true what you
said about kids because as they're
figuring out their emotions they might
they're gonna mirror how they see adults
for one reacting and getting upset but
there's also themselves just trying to
show their anger and show why they're
feeling sad or frustrated or upset or
hurt or angry and so they might start
throwing things or slamming doors or or
yelling or saying names and stuff and
instead of just like punishing the child
for
reacting in a way that is not desirable
instead going up to them and say you're
feeling really mad right now can you say
i feel so mad right now instead of
saying i hate you you know like hate
your i hate my brother you could say i'm
so mad right now i'm so mad that he did
that and just identifying those feelings
goes such a long way and the romantic
relationship
completely because it's so easy to just
blow up at your partner because you've
been holding it all day yeah and then
you start telling them this whole essay
of things that they've done wrong and
yeah they're like whoa
i just forgot to take the trash out it's
not that big of a deal and you're
holding on to all last week's everything
that i did wrong exactly just naming it
just putting if you can put a label on
that feeling it will really really
transform the way that you move through
your emotions as well as the way your
partner can understand you and how you
guys can tackle things and then like you
mentioned it's it's great for kids as
well and i i love watching videos on
conscious parenting yeah because not a
parent yet but one day i will be so i i
love seeing how there is a whole new
wave of really conscious parenting
happening where people can allow their
children to have their feelings
validated like you're mad right now
that's okay it's yeah being it's okay to
be mad yeah it's okay it's part of being
a human good job i get mad sometimes too
yeah just like relating to that person
and i love what you said about the
sweeping under the rug of how just
because there's another analogy from
another from a book that i read called
his needs her needs and it's pretty it's
pretty like you know old school
traditional so i don't love certain
parts about it but there's certain parts
i really really love i mean i love
traditional aspects too but it's just
the way that some of the parts in the
book is you know labels like females
versus males right when it could totally
be swapped even though just to clarify
the book does cl like acknowledge that
it could be swapped you know it really
just depends um on each relationship but
you know just clarifying that yeah
but what i love about the book is it
talks about the love bank and it's
similar to what you're saying about
sweeping under the rug and i think a lot
of people don't really realize or kind
of forget about how all relationships
when they start with that spark and that
excitement and that just total like over
the moon for each other those endorphins
are high it's literally like a drug like
you can't like you're in this total
other altered state where when you see
that person everything about you is just
just like addicted loving just so so so
into it it affects your whole mood your
day everything and as the relationship
prolongs and settles
it settles a little bit and you and
sometimes people expect all
relationships just be on that ultimate
high in the very beginning forever and
so then it's easy to move on and be like
oh well now that we're experiencing all
these issues right it's easy like well
we're just not in love and anymore
because it wasn't how it was in the very
beginning when really what's happened is
that endorphin high that happens in the
very beginning relationship has settled
and now all the issues are starting to
come to the front to the top of your own
issues yeah and how you respond to each
other so instead of being like oh now
i'm gonna look for that next high that
next super high and just move on because
trouble starting to happen in a
relationship or uncomfortableness
instead facing on head-on with what
you're going through and learning how to
heal from that
goes such a long way and learning like
love languages it's kind of like the
love language book the five love
languages but it goes a step further and
notice and expands to like 10 specific
needs and we have certain ones that are
more important to us than others
depending on each person so there's like
the love coin the love bank at the
beginning of your relationship and
everything you're doing is like you're
being your best self you're putting
forth your best foot forward to be your
best version of yourself to the person
that you're just so excited about and
then once it settles down you just often
kind of let that go and you're like
these things that aren't so desirable
about you start to show up and then you
start not treating them in the way you
maybe did in the beginning and so in the
beginning you're adding all these coins
to your to the bank and then as time
goes on if you aren't careful and
conscious of how you're treating your
partner you're going to start doing
things that take coins out of your bank
so everything you do with your partner
is either adding love or taking away
from love so how you react to things
like kind of like what you said you're
coming to them with like a issue and
you're feeling upset and they're just on
their phone or acting like
why are you even getting into this i
don't want to talk about this or
dismissing your feelings that is taking
a coin out of the bank and eventually if
you take all those coins out there's
nothing left
so that i just really like that we we
actually use that analogy as well with
the deposits
and withdrawals deposits and withdrawal
so sometimes if we're feeling you know
like the our our love bank has had a lot
of deposits and not enough uh
sorry a lot of withdrawals and not
enough deposits you know we'll mention
it to each other and just say hey you
know i feel like we've been doing a lot
of withdrawals lately we've been going
we've been having a lot of heavy
conversations like we had a fight the
other day like we really need to put
some deposits and it can help you to
have some more
you know clear intentions of okay we
need to put some deposits in like let's
plan a date night like let's plan a
beach day with our phones turned off and
just so we can spend time getting back
into that like feel-good feeling
yeah let's do a picnic let's take a bath
like we we have all these things that we
know are deposits that we both love to
do and it creates intimacy and that is
what
you know puts more in the bank account
or puts more in the our our relationship
bank account and i also back to the
conscious relationship part i was
thinking about if i would like to add
anything yeah i would i think that
one big part of it is
not
expecting your partner to
fill your needs and and really taking
ownership of you are
your own
whole complete person and it's not their
responsibility to make you happy it's
their responsibility to add to your own
happiness so it's not their job to fill
you up whenever you're
whenever you feel drained like it's your
it's always your responsibility to do
that for yourself and not project that
onto them because i feel like like what
you just mentioned of in the beginning
of a relationship somebody can it's all
love and butterflies and it's all great
things and
that person now might have an
expectation of this person has to do all
these things for me until from the end
of time or else i'm not going to be
happy that's not how it works every
relationship takes work but it's first
it's codependency but first and foremost
it takes you to do the work on yourself
and then you always have to show up to
the relationship with your best foot
forward and
that is what ultimately makes a really
successful relationship because if not
you fall into the trap of these unspoken
expectations can which then can lead to
resentment which then can lead to deeper
issues within the within the
relationship and that's where the
unspoken aspect is so key because we can
have these expectations right for from
our partner and when they're not doing
that and you're like well they must not
love me when really a lot of it is just
lack of communication and how you
receive love best so you might be like
i'm i'm taking out the trash and i'm
putting all the kids to bed by myself
and i'm cleaning all the dishes like why
don't you feel loved like this is how i
show my love and you're like well that
those that's great i love that you do
that and i don't want you to stop doing
that but like what really helps me what
makes me feel the most loved is through
your words or through your quality time
yeah like whatever that aspect that's
why i love the love five love languages
part but what you said is so key about
like centering for yourself and not like
the codependency part is so pivotal too
in that in that component because so
many people do get codependent and
expect that their partner is what makes
them happy when that's not
the reality at all so what books do you
guys recommend for
couples maybe from someone who's
experienced infidelity or they're
wanting to work on their relationship or
just relationship books in general that
you guys have found really helpful yeah
for somebody who has experienced
infidelity and been on the side of being
cheated on
i would recommend a book called
transcending
post post-infidelity stress disorder so
transcending pisd
the doctor's name slips my memory at the
moment but um that's a really helpful
book it talks about you know uh
post-infidelity stress disorder is a
real thing i mean it's it's really
traumatic so um that kind of talks about
how to deal with it whether or not you
want to
you know re-kindle reignite a
relationship with that person or not i
think that's really helpful book yeah i
would say i would i also read the book
like like whenever she found it and told
me that she was reading it this is
whenever we were broken up too yeah
i read it i read it because i wanted to
know what i could do to help
yeah help her healing process as well
and even i learned you know being the
one that cheated or the one that was
unfaithful
i learned about myself through that book
too because it also talks about things
that i had never considered might affect
my perspective on relationships and it
was one of them was like were your
parents in faithful like does that have
any role in how you show up or how you
see
the sanctity of your relationship and it
was just really eye-opening so that is a
great book for anybody that has
experienced it even as an as a as a kid
you know it's not just within a romantic
relationship is like you can have that
pisd from childhood as well which is
really
it was new to me so maybe i'll be new to
somebody else and the other one that i
would really recommend is
getting the love you want i don't know
if you've read that one too it's really
good so it's written by these a couple
these licensed couple therapists who
they're kind of pioneered the field of
imago therapy which
imago is essentially
the compository image that we
create as a child that has
all of our unmet childhood needs and all
of the qualities that our primary
caretakers had both the positive and the
the negative qualities that we
unconsciously seek to reconcile as an
adult so
if you find yourself in a relationship
and you see you find yourself saying
like oh this person reminds me of my mom
there's there's some truth to that
because you are naturally drawn to the
qualities that your mother may have had
the the
the nice ones you might also be drawn to
the not so great qualities that your
mother embodied and subconsciously
project
your partner to provide you with the
things that your mother never did so in
in my experience uh in in my personal
you know my childhood my my mother
suffered from mental health issues
and i consistently found myself in
relationship with women who suffered
from like diagnosed depression and i
never understood why and also suicidal
ideation or suicidal tendencies and i
did not know how to respond in those
situations i went
shut down straight into child mode or
whatever
adaptations i learned as a kid to deal
with my mother being in those situation
situations so now as an adult
i didn't know how to navigate those
and it wasn't until we started really
uncovering and unpacking our childhood
is when i shared with her about my mom
and the severity of what i experienced
as a kid or just the impact that those
events had on me as a kid and learning
how to navigate when i get activated or
learning how to
come forward and share how i'm feeling
whenever i was a kid but
it made so much sense and that book
really does a great job of
of learning how to learn more about
yourself and how to understand each
other's maybe childhood wounds and how
to navigate those challenging really
challenging conversations yeah yeah
getting the love you want is definitely
like a top like i feel like every couple
should read that book yeah awesome and i
love that you read the book on
infidelity that was meant for the one
who had been cheated on because it helps
you come to a place where you can
empathize and start to try to relate to
what the other person experienced that's
what's ultimately what
it's all about when it comes to how you
choose your relationships and to trying
to empathize with your partner and all
of it so i think that's a really big key
component
so
to kind of end off something i've seen
you say is that relationships are an
opportunity to grow deeper within
ourselves so what advice would you give
your younger self about relationships
that you wish you knew before
oh man so much i wish my younger self
could listen to this podcast yeah
um i would say
um
[Music]
i would say that
uh
you know to
that that honesty um honesty is so so
valuable and what that means really is
not just being honest with the other but
being honest with yourself because
even though i really valued honesty and
for me i was the type of person who was
like i've never cheated in a
relationship before
i i don't lie i hate lying but i was a
massive people pleaser so i was lying in
a way you know i was i was sacrificing
things that i wanted to do because of
what my partner and my past partners
what they wanted for me and so you know
i had a a
lot pretty long-term relationship before
i even met nemai where my partner did
not like what i posted on instagram he
didn't like the way i dressed and i
completely changed who i was for this
person
and at the same time was like i'm an
honest person with integrity you know
but i was lying to myself i was
suppressing who i was for another person
so
i would just really say that you know
honesty is so valuable and that doesn't
just mean being honest with with with
people and with your words it means
being honest with yourself like be your
most authentic
radically honest self first and foremost
and show up into all relationships that
way
i love it yeah you stole you stole what
i was going to say authentic expression
you know if if you show up as your fully
authentic self the moment you meet
somebody they know what they're going to
get but if you show up as this version
of yourself that's trying to put on a
front that's trying to make them like
you it's going to become exhausting to
try to keep that up for long term and
it's going to unravel eventually so it
may be
hard you might feel like it's harder to
find a partner but what that's doing is
that instead of making
you
trying to be liked by everybody it's
you're you're attracting the right
person into your life that likes that
likes you for you in all of your quirks
in all of your imperfections in all of
your things that
you thought other people might find
unattractive those are the redeeming
qualities that this person
finds attractive in you so if you could
be that from the beginning then
i i think that's going to set you up for
a really successful
deeply intimate relationship that'll
last yeah absolutely and that goes back
to even just what we were saying about
the when you're in that height of the
beginning of the relationship that
you're trying to just you know be the
best version and to help them fall in
love with you because you're so in love
with them it's just like a natural
reaction almost because you're just so
like
enamored with that person but there's a
balance of like being your best self
versus being somebody that you're not
yeah definitely that's definitely gonna
change like fall into trouble as you get
older or as it goes on this was so
amazing i appreciate everything you guys
shared and i think it's all so helpful
and i appreciate your vulnerability so
where can people find you guys and now
you have your own podcast that people
should definitely check out so we just
share that so people can continue to
like learn from your guys's experiences
yeah my podcast is the bianca taylor
podcast which i have an episode with you
coming out soon on parenting and vegan
stuff which is really exciting yeah and
we i do we have all other episodes on
relationships as well there and i'm on
instagram bianca taylor m tick tock
bianca taylor m and i'm also you know my
my podcast is also on youtube which is
bianca taylor fit perfect yeah same just
need my delgado on everything he might
all go to youtube podcast instagram
twitter
tick tock all of the stuff so pretty
easy to find there's not too many nema's
out there
as long as you just search my name
you'll find me i know and you guys have
been vegan a long time people who like
maybe are just learning about you you've
never eaten meat right in your whole
life yeah yeah i was born into a
vegetarian family and then went vegan uh
back in 2015 so
over seven years ago seven and a half
years ago now how about you um i've been
vegan for about nine years and did you
guys get together when did you guys get
together we met yeah we met when i had
already been 17 2017 so i had been vegan
for a couple of years already and you
weren't vegan yet i was oh you were
vegan i was 2017 yeah yeah we were both
vegan which also made our relationship
i mean like that's more compatible now
you bonded that's why we met like yeah
because yeah we were vegan and
we were like cool vegan yeah
whereas like andrew and i you know we i
was neither of us were vegan or
plant-based at the time so we started we
were 15 and 16 and then i came to him
one day when i was 19 like babe i'm
gonna go vegan and he's like what
and then a few years later he ended up
going vegan and that's actually that's
actually something that we
talk about quite a bit is
one partner in a relationship
wanting to go vegan or
already vegan and their partner is not
and like how to navigate those
those conversations and
um it's something that a lot of people
do deal with unfortunately like i love
this person but there's this like
fundamental
part of myself that i can't i can't
violate you know with the within myself
so but i really want them to to see the
world the way i do and it's like yeah
that's something that's challenging for
a lot of people have you guys done an
episode on that because that's a really
interesting topic no i think we should
not fully but we help our clients with
it
yeah we've talked about it many times
but i think it does deserve its own
episode because it goes within the
conscious relationship aspect that like
you really can't change anybody
like you can't change someone all you
can do is work on yourself and be your
best like be the best example that yeah
but navigating the thought process of
like especially if you're already
together and you and then you become
vegan the other isn't interested that's
such an interesting dynamic yeah okay
anyways i'm sure we could keep going but
i'm gonna end it here and thank you so
much for coming out i am so happy with
how this went and i just love everything
you guys have to share yeah thank you
for having me so much for having us okay
bye
[Music]
you